so today we're gonna talk about seven
things you can do to lower your blood
pressure an extremely high blood
pressure would be we have the systolic
and the diastolic and by the way
systolic is the contraction of the heart
diastolic is the relaxation and it has a
lot to do with something called the
autonomic nervous system where you have
the flight-or-fight
it's called sympathetic and then the
rest and digest parasympathetic which is
the recovery in it's an active type of
system that helps calm things down so we
have a balance of those two parts of the
nervous system that are on automatic so
we're looking at here extreme high would
be 180 systolic or greater than that or
greater than 110 diastolic high stage
one would be 160 to 179 systolic and
diastolic would be 100 to 109 high stage
to be 140 to 159 systolic 90 to 99
diastolic
normal high 139 to 121 systolic and 81
to 89 diastolic in normal 120 to 80
the important thing to know is that if
you get high blood pressure just one
time it's not very valid you want to
check it through the day and see if it's
consistent so the worst situation is
that if your blood pressure is high all
the time it never comes down and that
just means that your arteries are very
stiff and they're hardened versus it
fluctuating here and there that's a
better situation to handle there are
seven things that I would recommend
starting with you guessed it alpha keto
Y carbohydrates in general retain a lot
of fluid and what's one of the most
common medications that they use for
blood pressure diuretics they're getting
rid of excess fluid you go in keto
you're going to dump a lot of fluid and
there comes the blood pressure just by
going on a low-carb diet in a minute
fasting vital to decrease inflammation
in your arteries okay also the
combination is very very important to
take the stiffness out of the artery
itself
number three decreasing cortisol wets
cortisol cortisol is a stress hormone
from the adrenal and if the adrenals are
involved and the cortisol is too high
what's gonna happen is the systolic is
gonna go high first before the diastolic
conditions of high cortisol like
Cushing's syndrome is high blood
pressure but you'll normally see the
systolic go high first and you just want
to lower stress okay go for long walks
eliminate as much stress as possible I
have videos on this in fact I'll put a
link down below for one of them that
involves a stress webinar that I did
that will really help you reduce your
body stress number for taking vitamin d3
vitamin D actually will help lower your
blood pressure
your vitamin D deficient blood pressure
tends to go up they don't know exactly
why it does that one theory is that the
regulation of calcium supports the
sympathetic nervous system in a certain
way but it actually will lower your
blood pressure now increasing vitamin k2
what is vitamin k2 it's different than
k1 and this vitamin helps to remove
excess amounts of calcium from your
arteries and puts it in the bone so
these two together combined are really
important in lowering blood pressure can
number six this is probably one of the
more important ones increasing your
potassium there's an incredible article
written by several medical doctors that
involve taking larger amounts of
potassium to drop blood pressure with
incredible success if you're low on
potassium your blood pressure will go up
one of the main functions of potassium
is its ability to be a physiological
tranquilizer and just calm the nervous
system right down so it's a relaxer so
if you're deficient of potassium blood
pressure goes up and guess what creates
potassium deficiency refined sugars in
carbohydrates all right last one is
increasing magnesium if you're deficient
in magnesium your muscular system the
muscles within the vascular system are
going to be tight and the blood
pressures going to go up and it just so
happens that the foods that are high in
magnesium are also high in potassium
like in leafy
vegetables okay so these are the seven
things that you can do to lower your
blood pressure
thanks for watching
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it